[Music]
and my bad news
submitted by V and Chris what I had that
one a Florida man was arrested after
police mistook donut glaze for meth wait
it's glazed and not powder donut glaze
that's what meth looks like though net
looks like shattered grass out of all
people if you get donut glaze and then
you just you know when you get the
crusty yeah yeah it kind of looks like
men but then so he just like [ __ ] up a
whole bunch of French restaurants that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is his creme brulee
[ __ ] yeah so this man his name is Daniel
he's 64 years old from Orlando and so he
was arrested in December of 2015 on drug
charges so he was pulled over and then
that's when law enforcement spotted four
small flakes of glaze on his floorboard
and then so they thought the favorite
pieces of crystal meth and so they did
[Laughter]
pretty big like jump
wait this is in Florida yeah well that
makes sense it's like going into a
bakery you see flowers [ __ ] well
obviously it kind of makes sense it's in
the car right a lot of people smoke meth
and it's donuts but if you if you've
seen how donut glaze looks like just
kind of cuz I eat a lot in my car and I
throw trash all over the place I think I
kind of don't blame the cops on this one
guys okay I think I think they were
right on it
it went met do they do the that's what I
was gonna say like is that you it would
have like this is what we met because
cops you never put drugs in their mouth
unless they're dirty it's almost dirty
cops that did that cuz what if it's
anthrax and [ __ ] it's always dirty cop
what is this white substance that I know
nothing of it was rat poison
I would love to see that [ __ ] right he
just does that well clearly it's rough
here well [ __ ] that was Roach with Roach
powder or whatever you like bro
detective Johnson is out again on rat
poisoning well our time is here Johnson
I told you see my word I mean what
they're supposed to do is they have a
drug kit you guys jump on it that was
pretty funny though yeah for sure
so then the cops they had they performed
two roadside drug tests and they both
tested positive so yes Joe it's not
really the cops while I wait what do you
suppose it did but it's so much donut
company is like a bus is a huge donut
company things that be crazy
know so I've read this and previous
article can say that these roadside drug
tests are very faulty I remember a very
old JK news about these roadside drug
tests and they were sending people to
prison and all that but they even did
like experiments on all of them and just
putting water in there or whatever oh my
god oh he was so then he was arrested on
that and then weeks later a state crime
lab ended up clearing him we wait weeks
of the drag drug allegations and then
the charges against him were dropped but
he's been trying to open up his security
business and like he can't because of
his arrest record and he can't get any
jobs either so he answered why don't be
clear that record and say we [ __ ] up
that's a good question matter oh so then
he ended up suing the city of Orlando
and he
he's now received a $37,500 settlement
oh that's it you should get millions
million milli he deserves more and you
know why okay here here's my thought
process right he wanted to build a
company the potential that he could have
made with the security company for the
rest of its and then he kicked in not
only that he can't get a decent job and
his name is tarnished yeah this is
millions do people have gotten more for
less
and you don't even know how much he's
already invested in a security company
like he could have already bought 50
guns already got all the polo shirts and
I got all those black shiny shoes you
know I got the belts I got the Pataki
year old men to work I hired ya all
these ex-cons and bikers I only see old
little old man security guards no Daniel
that's uh yeah that your initial point
though the fact that I cops should have
known it was Dona Clea
they should have been able it tastes
like mrs. Krispy Kreme not the other
place Mobile on yeah what day was made
where the sugar themed film how long ago
that was like the most popular response
to this story though the fact that what
cops didn't notice that it was donut lee
why would he settle for 30 something
thousand was her [ __ ] lawyer dude
fire him what I'm hoping is it's 37,000
plus a clean record that's what I'm
hoping that's the most important thing
yeah cuz if it was 37,000 and a clean
record and I can create my security
company thanks a lot guys we could be
cool and he's already built rapport with
the police right so then if he builds a
security cupcake there's positive
positive
dude that's genius and if they start
putting meth on donut glaze right now
they're gonna start doing meth donuts
Mona Mona Mona no no I'm gonna go get
more nuts I wanna cook meth you want
away
well that's from saying the blue stuff I
really I'm not saying that he made it
look like it was easy but what I'm
saying is that he made it look like it
was easy I really want
do it you know what I liked about this
show it made me go I wish I paid more
attention in chemistry it's like dude
chemistry could break down the [ __ ]
world for the better and it's that point
too I just you know it just shows you
shouldn't be greedy you should be
grateful for what you have because when
he made that money he should have
bounced but he wanted more because he
wanted more respect than he wanted to be
the man on top yeah
what's my name I usually Malcolm's dad
what I usually talk very positively
about the usage of drugs
not that I'm okay with it but the three
drugs that I do not want society to do
is meth heroin heroin and coke / crack
well now these new one Guinea girl
empanada yeah I love that crocodiles
thought the crocodiles but ice in Russia
I'm sure that's their problem that's a
[ __ ] that like peas and then you inject
it and then it starts eating away your
skin oh because Russia's a weird place
huh I must be really good
that's what I said we only want drugs
that can kill us because we are not
[ __ ] drug that make me go blind in one
eye
I don't know drug is worth nothing I
feel like those are the drugs that you
already did your hair oh and you already
did your cocaine but you don't have any
more money because you live in a sewer
so then you have 30 cents and then you
buy that [ __ ] you start [ __ ] spraying
Windex on your tongue this is what
happens when you're on drugs show the
world thank you forever I want to feel
what you're doing right now
it's on the mountain oh that looks like
a really good piece of prosciutto
what is that bone it is and pus it's
muscle decay they inject it and then
like yeah it eats it eats your muscle
God what the [ __ ] holy really poor
people driver did you see that
it proves my point though cuz did you
see that picture she didn't look like
she had any remorse she's like I'm not
busine I was high as [ __ ] your drug has
no adverse side effect [ __ ] who wants
to hotbox with me do this a truck [ __ ]
Alex craziest fall that makes people
look like zombies and [ __ ] this one lady
she like her eyes are like this nobody
looks like flickers it looks like you're
gonna fly away with your face when
you're rolling really hard on drugs and
then you look at lights and that's what
your eyes do when you start popping
pills there's so many movies I mean TV
shows like coming out like Breaking Bad
and [ __ ] narcos and it's making for
this is so cool you know but what they
need to do is change it up because like
yeah I thought that's what those shows
are about is to is to make people feel
like I want to be a drug dealer
it's a motivational TV show you wanted
to be a cop not a drug dealer
I like Hank on the show gusto Hank was a
little too nosy for us all damn good
very no he's very nosy and why you be so
[ __ ] nosy by liking these rules I
think for the rest of us we just want to
sell drugs and we go hmm what if what if
what would it be like I want to sell
drugs without I want to sell drugs
without having to murder innocent
families and getting caught I mean like
you know like the cartel wars were like
you felt good my friend I mean it I'm
gonna kill you whole entire family that
kind of thing I was I was i sold but i
was never a part of that life mmm yeah
you were like yeah
like you know I was I didn't because I
think for sure if I sold drugs at that
type of level I look I would cut out
early
yes song is the high God but you can't
though you're stuck because like
breaking bad like people relied on you
to deliver what you can't you can't pass
the torch how does it work when you're
like you pushed a hole shits on you move
that much and then you're like you know
what man I want to return home there's
no retirement oh that's why in narcos
the Cali cartel we're trying to do that
[ __ ] oh man finish the season cartel was
trying to get out of the drug business
but the lower-level people said but what
about us
you don't have anything else to do no I
kind of like this life we're gonna throw
away this life with the clubbing and the
girls and the drinking and the power
[ __ ] that thanks for watching guys and
those are our thoughts what are your
thoughts don't forget to comment below
we want to know what you guys are
thinking but don't write anything that
will make it sad or make us mad because
after all we're just kidding news and
we're a very happy channel for the last
video click up here
[Music]